[Music]
[Applause]
and okay hello hi hello yes it's a year
today by the way guys didn't know hello
and 2014 is actually what I think a very
good year to be doing web development
and me like what are you guys here
probably well probably all of you guys
pretty much do things in a browser and
and I think as a web developer I'm just
gonna share with you guys I kind of feel
like our profession is a little taken
for granted around here and there's this
pretty good studio that's pretty
well-known Tehan and lex and this is
their tagline it says if an atlas screen
we will design for it and it's it's a
very bold claim to make and it's
actually probably what every one of you
guys do your day-to-day imagine that if
it has a screen we will build her it
will design for it and that is what we
do what I do and what you guys do every
day and I think that's some brilliant
thing and all of that is like what
happened after like decades of history
of web development so at some point in
the past you know what development
wasn't really much no one really thought
of it so much you know there's pretty
much content with things that look like
this but of course history happened and
at some point people got together and
said like hey let's standardize this
thing called HTML and stop fighting over
what should be standards and let's just
mandate this is what should be going on
moving forward and this was something
that was pretty hard to do over at that
time if you could understand if you guys
are familiar with these kinds of things
and that happened just last millennium
97 and fast-forward many many years a
couple of things happen until the
invention of something called I believe
it's called a smart phone yeah so that's
the smart phone yeah so okay might say
I'm a little unfair calling that
smartphone because there were other
smartphones before that but reality is
after that came out everything else just
kind of looked like that anyway so might
as well anyway a couple of a couple of
more years going along we have so many
ideas we have so many technologies
coming forward external five CSS and
eventually we came into this whole idea
of like hey maybe we could design for
any screen in the world which is the
same things that we have been using the
whole time then turns out the technology
to do that has been around for way too
long and media queries have been you
know it's been existing before anyone
ever thought of responsive design this
is an article from OS depart and that
was just 2010 and media crews were
already existing way back then so that
sort of thing just happened around 2010
and a couple of other things just came
up and we have so many things that we
could do on a browser on your computer
on your phone we can get someone from
one point of the country to another and
tell them the exact directions right on
your browser and we could play videos
we've made text editors I think there's
like two at least two out of know
there's probably even more than that
text editors IDs made in just a browser
we've made games in a browser but I
think after all these developments over
the year searches this one Corino
problem that nobody has ever really
solved elegantly in the realm of
browsing and in the realm of web
development and I think that is vertical
centering
so that's it I'm Rico Santa Cruz you
might know me around some open source
project as our star cruise and this is
me talking about how to use flexbox to
save your sanity all right okay going
back to your vertical centering so I
went to the Internet like everyone does
everyday looking for answers and it came
across this and it's been asked five
years ago and just like so many answers
those fourteen answers on this one and
they had to lock the thread because
people kept responding and I don't know
at some point I'm sure everyone has
thought of like how do you do vertical
centering and when I was like mute CCSS
I mean when this whole CSS positioning
thing was just really taking off I
thought it was really easy you know I
thought it was just like this so that's
my purse at temp and probably everyone
else is too right and this is for those
who haven't done that this is what it
looks like so obviously that's not
really gonna work so you go back and see
like what did you do wrong maybe there's
something you've missed maybe Center or
not middle and you go like oh I know
maybe you should use it to container and
after that this is what it looks like
and you go back and still don't really
know maybe it's both and maybe it'll
work and this is again what it looks
like so it's not really a solution so I
went on the internet very recently and
looked like how do people solve this so
if you guys want to do that right now go
ahead but I've done the research for you
I'm just gonna show you okay if it's
just one line you do a line height trick
wherein you set the same line height for
the same height if it's a fixed type you
could do like a position:absolute top
50% did I get it margin you could do
something like a table sell you can do
fixed margin top you can do pretty much
I don't know there's like 10 odors and
ran out of space of the slide so there
are so many ways to do it anyway moving
forward there's this thing called
flexbox I'm not sure if you guys right a
bit I'm sure you guys have but I'm sure
not everyone has really used it because
you know everyone's kind of averse to
using it anyway it's really really
simple really simple actually there are
very long articles I was very
intimidated about it but it turns out
it's all really broken down to just two
basic things you just set something on
the container and set something on the
on the items something called display
flex and flex something so it's very
perfect for things like for for
basically app you eyes and you know
these kinds of things that can tend to
pop up every now and then like sidebars
and menus and stuff like that and
there's a little quick yet to dispel a
couple of beauties flex lock is actually
pretty well supported right now so these
is these are the browsers that support
the new version of flex box there's
actually two versions of flex box the
old one and a new one this is the the
one with the support for the new ones if
you notice these are very recent
browsers and if you go back to the ones
that support the old syntax and it's
even actually way back whether it's
Firefox - I don't even remember that an
Android Eclair right and that's pretty
much 2006 so we've actually had browsers
that support flex bucks for a while now
the only stickler here is IE 10 so it's
it's not really good if you're targeting
IE but if you're making something that
targets mobile and ipads iphones that's
pretty good because you're probably not
really caring about that so much anyway
and if you use flexbox for things like
these these are pretty much what is
really made for you just really set like
a display flex on the container and you
set something called flex and the items
and that's pretty much what all we need
to do and there's just three magic
numbers and they mean these things
basically
so all you really need to do is display
flex on a container and the item
something called flex property and it
just is really as three magic numbers
yes it looks it's emitting it's actually
pretty simple grow is usually like zero
or one if it's what it means it's
flexible if it's zero it's not you can
actually use other numbers but more on
that later and shrink is what if it's
too small
am i is a browser allowed to shrink it
more than the basis so basis is like the
where's based out of you know what's
default with sort of and it's actually
pretty flexible not all three are
required sometimes you usually just
specify one or two so you guys can check
out I'm posting a link later so if you
won t cheated this out there so you
could just define which once you really
need and in the real world probably look
like this so if you do something like a
fixed type awhile ago
it looks like zero zero and whatever the
height is and if you want an extendable
it's just really Auto which is the same
as one one auto and it's pretty much I
don't know I climbed to stop the server
now because it's really most of the
things you need to know but anyway let's
go on so if you want to space it out
something like this like evenly you can
actually put margins around around each
item and they would be honored by flex
bug that's just gonna work like how you
usually would expect if you know like
you probably use margin:0 auto at some
point and that thing just kind of works
for vertical as well and if we go back
to the problem of vertical centering
it's you're not gonna believe that this
works but it does so that's just really
it and it gets pretty clean centered
sure thing
lovely so that's pretty much how you do
a vertical centering you just do a
margin on the item or the other way is
you can also modify
container instead of the item to have
more control this is a property called
justified content there's actually more
possible values for this but the ones
you're probably going to be using the
most is space around which means even at
the spacing vertically and there's
pretty much two of them justified
content is like vertical and a line
items is horizontal and that would also
get you a vertical Center and if you
notice this one you're styling a
container and set it there instead of
the box instead of the item it's telling
a parent instead and that would be
enough to get you to a vertical
centering just like that and essentially
thing about this is it's actually right
now it kind of looks like how you would
expect tables to work or something but
the really interesting things happen is
what if you combined that with media
queries so what could how could you make
something that would work as well on a
desktop and a tablet and a phone and the
thing is since these are all just really
CSS properties and you could just
restyle them anytime you need to say put
a media query for a tablet and just want
to change the Flex direction from column
which is to make things vertical to row
you just it's just really one little
property right there and that's really
perfect for things like you know when
you're switching from tablet to mobile
and another thing is you could even
reorder things without changing the dump
order so you just go through that icon
just went from right to left and you
just really have to change order this
little CSS property called order and you
could just set an order for any one of
those property if any one of those
elements and you can just reorder them
depending on your media query so if you
put all these things together and you
just put a little media courier right
here and basically it says that whenever
you're on a we're on a phone you're
going to make it vertical and you're
going to reorder the a bike
so in reap and practice this is what
it's probably going to look like and
that's it you were able to make a menu
with very very little modifications to
your CSS and uh if anyone wants to
follow along this this example is
actually posted over at github and old
flat sheet paper URL later on and
basically this entire thing is built out
of flex box just really every just like
all the macro layout is all made out of
flex box and the fantastic thing is it's
you could also nest your flex boxes so
you can have like three elements for
your main columns their main panes and
that's just your regular flex box kind
of properties so this one is on 20% 80%
of the other puts like min and Max with
just to make sure it doesn't collapse
too far and that's pretty much it you're
going to have like perfect columns on a
desktop but please by the way right if
anyone wants to follow along I tweeted
the link you can just check out my
twitter and link is over there and and
so this is what it looks like play okay
so basically just do the same kinds of
things wherein you take the take this
kinds of flexbox kind of properties and
put a little media elements and just
change the orientation from horizontal
to vertical and you just get a really
nice responsive almost effortlessly so
again it's just really all nested
flexbox so this is how it probably would
look like under your typical app where
you have like a horizontal kind of setup
and it would flatten out to a vertical
one whence you shrink your browser and
as you notice like you could just hide
one of the panes whenever you are in a
mobile just display knowing or some
things and that would be fine and just
nest flex spots within a flex box
so even the things inside the delisting
is a flex bucks and a flex bucks
so the menu you saw that a while ago
though and that listing is actually
pretty simple just like that and then
the pastor would probably do something
like this in like position absolute
position fixed with like top left bottom
right and fixed pixels but now at least
there's something more flexible and and
the thing is you can the wonderful thing
here is if you want to add like say a
search bar or something just right under
it it's pretty easy just insert another
dumb element and put like another flex
thing over there and that's it you could
you can pretty much change your eye up
any time you want and if you notice this
is actually it turns out to be something
that could actually work and here it is
like I don't know like 40 additional
lines of JavaScript so you make it kind
of do its thing and that's it we
actually we're able to make a pure CSS
approach to this whole responsive deal
and there's no fancy JavaScript to like
what happens when you size it down you
need to hide this and that just pretty
much that and all that was able to be
accomplished with Flex box by the way
right here here is the Twitter and you
can just check out the link over there
if you want to look at the source so
trying to say is right now what temp cui
layout problems it's pretty much solved
when it comes to something that would be
on mobile and it's something that really
makes you lets you integrate things
really really fast because if you really
want to rearrange things or just want to
add and subtract and add you panels new
layouts you just really have to just add
another element and flex buckles take
care of trying to lay that out for you
and if you try to go through like you
know different websites out there a
couple of them can be solved but flexbox
really so they're a couple of there's a
lot of scene in the properties he could
also use for flex bucks it like say for
example align cell flex and is something
you would probably use a set of
float:right which while it goes pretty
much said that floats are evil so flex
logs is another way to get around it and
if you go to like content area it's
pretty much the same kind of deal and
you can even use a shorter flex box
syntax just flex 5 and flex 3 so
basically if you just specified the
growth parameter it's kind of trying to
figure out which one's bigger and which
one smaller and you know based on each
one's relative growth parameter and yeah
say this one - could be salt it's pretty
much everything is just really a grit
everything is just a something that can
be solved with nested layouts and
fantastic thing is if you if you're able
to do it if you could implement like a
layout like slack over something like
this it can be responsive down to tablet
so imagine like you could just say hide
the sidebar or no go to your under
sidebars to make sure that it could also
work in its head what so most of them
for the most part it's something that is
pretty much solved right now and if you
go to can I use comm the only thing that
really is slowing down the adoption of
flex bucks right now
is ie because the minimum thing the
minimum version that really supports
flex bucks for real as I
ie 11 so but as far as like the mobile
mobile adaptation even some of the older
iPhones older androids are able to
support it so it's something that is
actually pretty usable when it comes to
mobiles
so and if you're gonna do something like
mobile do I suggest you give it a try
and that's it for me so that's me Rico
and that was the lunch on flexbox
[Music]
[Applause]